Good morning.
From the time of Julius Caesar.
We have seen the rulers of Rome Brag
about building buildings that were bigger
than any others in the world.
You'll remember Cesar referred to his,
uh,
to his temple of Mars in that way that
he was building the largest temple of
Mars in the world.
Uh,
and we also saw the same for demission
with his palace on the Palatine Hill for
Trajan with his enormous forum
for, uh, Hadrian building,
the greatest largest dome that
had been built up until that time.
And as we discussed,
uh,
still the largest diameter dome in the
city of Rome today and Hadrian's villa at
Tivoli.
Just as a selection of examples we're
going to see today that have bigger,
was better,
biggest is best.
And in the case of the Emperor Caracalla,
uh,
an emperor who was a
megalomaniac megalomaniac in the,
in the tradition of Nero and Domitian,
that he built the largest
imperial bath structure to date.
And we're going to be looking at
that bath structure today. Uh,
and we're going to see it is really a
colossal and fascinating building in all
kinds of ways. But before
I get to that, in fact,
we'll end with that bath structured today.
Before I get to that,
I would like to look with
you at a architecture in
Rome in the second and third
centuries.
Ady and we'll see that architecture is
quite varied in terms of whether it's
private, it's civic.
Uh, it's also funerary.
I want to,
uh,
begin though by just reminding you
of what we talked about last time.
We looked at the city of Australia
and we looked at the city of Osteo,
the port of Rome in its entirety.
Once again, it's public buildings,
it's civic structures, it's
commercial enterprises. Uh,
and we also went at the very end of the
lecture out to easily software where the
tombs of the, of the, uh, of the,
of those who lived in
an Osteo were located.
And I show you a couple of those again
now on the screen. These brick face tombs,
these tombs that are made of concrete
at easily Socra that were put up for the
professionals, but the
traders, the commercial,
a merchants and so on that
lived in the city of Ostia. Uh,
they were made of brick,
face, concrete construction.
They had barrel bolts or
groin vaults inside. I do,
can see also that they
were faced with brick, uh,
and they were faced with brick
as we discussed that was exposed,
the idea of brick being
attractive in its own right,
if a fabulously beautiful facing,
uh,
that they take advantage
of in the second century,
a d a and decide not to stucco it over.
As you can see so well here,
the doorways into those tombs,
uh,
surrounded by travertine jams and
lintels the inscription in the center,
the small slit windows, and then,
uh, a pediment at the top. Uh,
we saw when we looked at funerary
architecture in the age of Augustus,
for example,
that it was very varied,
very varied p peer to tombs and the shape
of pyramids in the shape of a circular
tombs tombs that made reference to
bakeries like the tomb of the baker,
your Rissa keys.
There is still a certain amount of
variety in to market texture in the second
century, a d, but they tend to
hone in on one type in particular.
And that type is the so
called house to him type,
which is exactly what we see here at
tomb that is rectangular in shape for the
most part box like a and does
resemble very closely a house.
This close relationship that we've
talked about so many times this semester
between houses of the living
and houses of the debt.
So we looked at those last time and
where I want to begin today is just to
demonstrate to you that these same kinds
of house tombs that we see in Ostia and
easily soft grow in the second
century d we also see in Rome,
uh,
and in some cases they are commissioned
by individuals of comparable a social
status to those in Ostia,
but sometimes they are
commissioned by the most elite.
And I'd like to begin with an example of
a similar tomb commissioned by the most
elite. This is the so called
tomb of [inaudible] in Rome.
It was put up on the famous
via Apia or the Apia Ian Way.
It dates to around a d 161 in this case,
we know who the commissioner was and I
can show you what he looked like as well.
You see him here on the right
hand side of the screen.
He was a man by the name of her roadies.
Atticus.
I put his name on the monument
lists for you. Her roadies,
Atticus, uh, her roadies.
Atticus was actually a Greek. He was
Athenian, the Greek part of the empire.
He lived in Athens for the most part,
and he commissioned a very
famous music hall and Odi on,
which still survives a, you can see it
over here. It's without his roof today,
but it was originally one of these roofed
music halls in Odi on it is located on
the slope of the Acropolis in Athens.
The Acropolis that of course,
we know primarily for its
great architectural feats
of the fifth century BC in
Greece. This is the Roman building put
up by her roadies in the second century.
Uh, and we see it on the
slope of the Acropolis,
very well preserved in modern times.
It's great as fame is the fact that
Jani performed his live at the Acropolis
concert, uh, at the Odi on of a Agrippa.
And even if you have a roadies addict is,
and even if you don't like Jani,
it's actually quite an interesting, a
concert to view and one can view it, uh,
in video and so on,
uh,
because it does take such wonderful
advantage of this extraordinary,
uh, ancient structure, as you know,
and he presents his music. At any rate,
uh, at one point, her roadies advocates
who had a lot of, um, connections,
not only in Athens but around
the empire at one point, uh,
through those connections, he gets
himself appointed a senator in Rome.
And in order to take up that position,
he needs to leave Athens, uh, behind, uh,
and go spend some time in Rome.
And he and his wife Andrea Magilla,
a set up house in Rome,
a Antia Magilla unfortunately dies in
Rome and he needs to bury her and he
decides to bury her in
Rome instead of in Athens.
And he bills for her,
a tomb on the,
on the [inaudible] way on the
via Apia in around 161 ID.
That's the date, the date
that we believe she died. Uh,
and we see a, a, a view of that, uh,
of that tomb here.
What we're looking at,
and you probably recognize this already
because we've looked at a number of
models from this museum of casts and
roam the Museo del achievable tall Romana
in ar in Rome.
And I show you two views of this model
of the tomb of Ani regular one that we
see from the front and another that we
see from if we're facing the monument,
the left side of the tomb.
And these are extremely helpful because
they give us a very good sense of what
we are dealing with here.
It is clear that we are dealing with a
tumor type that is not that different
from what we saw in Austria.
Although this looks more like a temple
then it looks like a house and you can
see that right off it looks exactly
like a typical Roman temple.
We see that it is on a high podium.
It has a deep porch,
it has a freestanding
columns in that porch.
It has a single staircase on the front
of the structure has facade orientation a
than an entrance way into the structure.
It also has freestanding
columns that support a pediment.
So if I were to show you this, uh, and,
and not identify it and say, do you,
what kind of a building is,
is,
I'm sure you would've said it was a temple
and you would have been right in the
sense that it looks most like a temple,
but it is a tomb in the form of a temple.
As you can see here,
uh, looking on the, uh,
on the side of the monument,
you can also see those same features
that I've just described. And while, uh,
we are looking at this view because
I'm not going to bring it back,
I want to point out one detail that
will loom large as we look further at,
at this structure.
Uh,
you will see on the left side of the,
uh,
of the of the tomb that the architect has,
has created, has kind of scalloped
out the side, uh, on either side,
creating niches, told
niches on, on the side,
and placed columns into that space,
which is a very unusual thing to do.
It's not true on the other
side of the monument,
only on this side of the structure.
Uh,
why has the architect that I
think it might have something
to do with the siding,
perhaps how you viewed it from the street.
Maybe it was skewed in such a way that
you would see not only the facade but
also the side. And he wanted to
emphasize the, uh, the, um, the, the,
the columns on that particular
side of the structure.
But it may also have just tapped to
do with, with a quirk, with this, uh,
particular interest that the,
uh,
that the architect or the patron had in
doing something different than any other
tomb. And I want to re, uh,
return to that point in a moment.
But most significant of all is that
in terms of the building technique,
the use of concrete
faced with exposed brick,
this is exactly what we saw in Ostia.
Uh,
and you can see that just as an Australia,
they have taken that brick as far as it
can go in terms of its aesthetic value,
uh,
by respecting the texture of the brick,
playing that texture off a play in color,
different colored bricks of reddish brick
against a more yellowish colored brick,
playing those off against one another.
Uh,
and then adding certain very highly
decorative decorative details, uh,
like a meander pattern that we're
going to see in a moment, uh,
and decoration around the windows
of the tomb done in Stucco.
The columns however, are marble columns
are marble. And in that sense, again,
something somewhat different
than what we saw at Ostia.
This is a view of the
tomb as it looks today.
The porch is not WellPreserved
and I can't show you any of that,
but I can show you the rest of the
structure and you can see it quite well in
this particular view. Uh, and again,
you see that it is indeed WellPreserved
concrete construction phase with brick
brick left exposed,
a respected and enjoyed in its own right.
What I've already described,
the playing off of one color
of brick against another,
this meander pattern done and
Stucco stucco declaration,
very elaborate decoration as we're
going to see a around the windows tall
podium. We see that here as well.
Uh, and extraordinary structure.
And what's interesting,
I think to note, uh,
at least culturally and in terms of social
status is the fact that although this
structure was put up for one
of the most wealthy men, uh,
in or the wife of one of the most wealthy
men in Rome at this particular time,
the general aesthetic is very similar to
what we saw for professional people in
the city of Ostia.
That is a concrete tomb in the form of
a house or a temple in this case, uh,
that is co that that has
as its facing brick, uh,
and a respect for that
brick in its own right here.
A couple of details.
I show you once again a detail
of the warehouse or the array a,
a Gothy Yanna at,
uh,
Ostia that we looked at a and also a
detail of the tomb of [inaudible] in Rome.
And I think you can see here what I mean.
Again,
the different coloration
of the yellowish brick,
the reddish brick played
off one against the other,
the use of a stucco
decoration in this case, uh,
for the volumes of the composite
capitals. Uh, in this case. And in fact,
in fact you'll remember I pointed out
what was interesting about these capitals
at the warehouse was that they were,
that the brick was used to make
up the main body of the, uh,
of the capitol.
And this is not one of them,
but I also showed you one where you could
see the way in which that brick form
the actual a campus leaves of the Capitol,
and then the volume it's added and Stucco.
We see the same thing at the tomb of
Antioch. Magilla we see those here.
I think you can see it.
Well,
the brick used to create the lower part
of the campus leaves and then Stucco
added for the curving part and for
some of the additional decoration,
the flower and so on, up above.
Uh, and so we see, and here again,
very elaborate decoration around the
windows, which we also saw at, uh,
the,
um,
warehouse in Ostia to more details
of the tomb of Ani irregular. Here.
You see what I was talking about before,
the way they,
the architect has scooped out to
areas on the left side of this,
of the tomb and place the columns
inside of those, which is a unique,
I don't know of any other example
of this enrollment architecture.
And it underscores once again that
when it came to two markitecture, uh,
that the,
uh,
that the patron could pretty much
do whatever he wanted as long as the
architects could build it.
Uh, it could, it could,
it could be quite idiosyncratic
as a form of architecture.
And we see not only has he scooped
out these niches in which to place the
columns,
but if you look at those columns very
carefully and at the bases of those
columns, you will see that they are
not round, they are multi-sided. Uh,
and the bases are also multi-sided.
So doing something very unique, uh,
in the context of this particular tomb.
A of an irregular.
So two main points,
one that there is clearly an aesthetic
that is used a four to market texture
concrete faced with brick,
uh,
that is used in the upper
most levels of Roman society.
And then further down in Roman society,
not only in Rome but also in Ostia.
Uh, but at the same
time, uh, individuality,
eccentricity is valued into marketecture
allowed into market texture in a way
that perhaps it isn't in other forms
of Roman architecture. And we see it,
uh, taken to its limit in this particular
building. I just a few more details.
We see a niche from the
tomb of Annie Magilla.
We also see here both the meander pattern
and this very elaborate decoration
around the windows,
uh,
a frame around the windows and then a
projecting element up above with these
great spiral volumes on either side.
Very similar to the same sort of
thing that was happening at Ostia.
I remind you of the niche in the
courtyard of the [inaudible],
the warehouses at Ostia where you see
the same sort of thing. Uh, these, uh,
stucco co, uh, pilasters added and Stucco,
the brick work creating
triangles and laws and Jews.
As you can see here, same idea over
here in the tomb of [inaudible] gala.
And if you look very closely at the
pediment that is located above the niche
from the tomb in Rome,
uh,
you see the projecting and
tablatures you see where the Co,
the capital's would have been.
There would also have been either call
probably columns added here on either
side of the niche,
making it look much more similar to here,
but look closely at the pediment.
You will see that there is projecting
and tablature on odd above each column.
But then in the center the
triangular pediment is cut back. Uh,
and that playing around with the
traditional vocabulary of architecture is
something that I've noted is going to
be a part of what we call the baroque
trend in Roman architecture.
I'm going to devote an entire lecture to
the baroque trend in Roman architecture
around the empire, not just enrollment,
but mostly in the provinces.
And we'll see that same sort of thing,
which creates a kind of in and
out a lively movement, uh, to the,
uh, to the facade that
is part of that approach.
The tomb itself again. Uh, and just
to point out, interestingly enough,
a couple of female figures with capital's
on there on the top of their head or
what looked like maybe more like
vases on the top of their head. Uh,
but looking very much like [inaudible].
It's like the car he audits we saw from
the Eric theone and Athens fifth century
BC from the forum of Augustus and from
Hadrian's villa around the Sarah pm.
Uh, they are not, they are not
duplicates of those in Athens.
Like the other two are a, but they
do seem to make reference to them.
They're a bit more casual. When
I look at these, this pair,
they always look to me like they're
kind of standing at a cocktail party
together and conversing with one another
using the usual adjusters that Italians
are so famous for. We see them doing
that sort of thing here, but even,
but they do seem to
have that same pedigree.
Going back to the whole idea of the car,
he audits and I only mentioned it to you,
they were found right near this
tomb and so it has been speculated,
although it is by no means certain that
they might have belonged to the tomb.
They might've been located
in front of the tumor,
had been some kind of for part of some
kind of for court or for space to that
tomb.
It's pure conjecture,
but it would be interesting if it were
the case because remember her odis addict
has comes from Athens.
We see that the tomb is a thoroughly
Roman tomb of the second century, a d.
Uh,
but it would be interesting to think that
he might have added some touches that
might have made some reference a for him
and also especially for his wife was to
him. It was a to the Athens
of his, uh, of his birth
with regard to tomb interiors in
the second century. Aidy in Rome.
There are two major types and I
want to treat both of those today.
One of them is a type that we've seen
before and that is where you stuck over
the interior of the tomb.
You will,
you stop it over and then you add
additional stucco in relief to a form,
the decoration and then you paint it.
Uh, that's one type. And the second type,
which might also use that for
the bald but for the walls.
The second type is to use
instead architectural members,
columns, uh, pediments and the
like to enliven the wall, uh,
and to create a much
more sculptural effect.
Both of these types are used
in Rome in the second century,
Aidy in to market texture. And I want to
show you examples of both of them today.
The first type one a with
stucco painted stucco.
We see in the so called tomb of the
Valarie, the tumor, the Valarie,
which dates to around a d 159 and is
located on the via Latina and in Rome.
We haven't looked at the,
uh, via Latina before. Uh,
but it is one of Rome's main streets
that had a long it a cemeteries and there
are a fair number of concrete tombs
faced with brick that are preserved very
well preserved on the via Latina today.
And what makes them particularly
special is the interiors are, uh, are,
are almost pristine. It's
quite extraordinary to go
into these and see how uh,
how well they have stood the test
of time. The tumor, the Valarie,
you see the lunette and the vault of
the interior of that tomb right here.
Uh, and uh, as you look at the, a
canvas leaves growing up in the, uh,
in the Lunette all done in stucco
relief and the barrel vault with its
individual compartments round and square
compartments with floating figures
inside. I, you should
certainly be reminded of things
we've already seen before.
When one looks at the Qantas leaves,
one ha can't help but think back to the
delicate leaves of the Arra pockets.
The delicate, a canvas leaves of
the Arra pop is our boost die.
Would you see on the left hand side
of the screen, and I'm sure you are,
as reminded is I am looking at this,
uh,
bald by other things that we
have seen earlier this semester.
What's this over here?
The domus salary.
It's one of the vaults
of the domus salary,
a third style done we believe
by fabulous himself. Uh,
and you'll recall very delicate,
very light floral motifs
compartments in this case,
rectangular with floating
sea creatures in the center.
We see exactly the same
sort of thing here,
although done in stucco instead of paint,
but this was painted originally
in antiquity and we see
these floating these new
ads on the back of sea creatures,
uh,
in inside floating inside these.
And we think the message here of course,
is of the soul of the deceased being
carried to the isles of the blessed by
these sea creatures. So very much
stucco decorations, second century, a d,
but very dependent on third style,
a Roman,
a wall painting and third style deck
stucco decoration of earlier dates,
uh, the tomb of the punk Crotty
in Rome, which dates to one 69.
Also on the via Latina has similar
similarly WellPreserved stucco decoration
also painted.
And I'll show you a color view in a
moment for you to get a sense of that
coloration. Uh, but here you get an idea
of the scheme of the wall. Very, very,
very elaborate stuccoed over stucco.
Much of the Stucco is done in relief.
You can see it here if the, uh,
if the stucco decoration
of the tomb of the Valarie,
he made reference to the third style.
I think the inspiration
here was fourth style,
a Roman wall painting and
stucco decoration. Uh,
because although you continue to see
floating mythological figures in these
rectangular or triangular compartments,
if you look very closely,
especially in this zone here,
you will also see these
architectural cages done in stucco.
Very similar to the architecturals cages
that we saw at the top of fourth style
Roman wall design.
So this taking its cue from
four style Roman wall painting.
And I had mentioned to you a couple of
times already this term that in fact most
Pompei it most postpone pay and painting
and Stucco decoration post 79 a d a
does seem to be inspired
by the third style,
but even more so by the fourth
style of Roman wall painting.
And we see that very well here with this
stucco decorating the Lou nets and also
the vaulting.
Here's a view in color of the
interior of the tomb of the pond,
Crotty e,
uh,
where you can see the same sort of
scheme that I've already described,
but with the color.
And you can also see that we are dealing
here with a groin vaulted interior. Uh,
and uh,
what's interesting is that sometimes the
walls have a small niches for urns and
the so called Arca Soliah.
I've mentioned those to you before,
that were used for the placement
of bodies once inhumane, uh,
became as popular in deed even
more popular than cremation.
But we also sometimes see
the sarcophagi themselves,
the free standing coffins, uh,
located in these tombs as we see here.
And it's interesting to keep in mind
that all of the money and time that was
expended on this interior decoration,
keep in mind that very few
people entered into these tombs.
When you looked at a tomb you
saw primarily it's exterior,
some family members on special
occasions might go inside,
but it was relatively rare. So all of
this, all of this done in fact to give uh,
the, the deceased, uh,
a pleasant home in perpetuity and to help
them on their journey to the isles of
the blessed this, this structure also
has sea creatures, uh, depicted in it.
So travel is clearly also alluded to
and scholars who have worked on this
particular monument in particular have
noted that they think it has to do with
one of these secret mystery religions. In
this case, the orphan, O, r, p, h. I. C,
the orphan,
a religion that was practiced in secret
initially and then eventually came up
above ground to more details of
the upon Crotty ceilings in Stucco.
These,
I think give you a particularly good
sense of the way in which they were built
up almost as reliefs. And some
parts of the scenes, uh, this, uh,
this figure here for example,
at some of the rest was painted.
We see heraldic leopards over
here on either side of a boss,
the shell and the niche, also
done in Stucco and raised
in a very sculptural way.
Uh,
and then the whole painted in a variety
of attractive maroons and blues and
Greens.
The most interesting to him from my
point of view actually, uh, is uh,
a tomb that is located a Roman tomb
of the second century that is located
beneath the Vatican today.
And I show you a view again of the Dome
of Saint Peter's Cathedral in Rome,
designed by Michelangelo himself.
Another view over here showing
also Michelangelo's Dome, uh,
but showing below it the so-called
ball, the Kino, uh, that was, uh,
put up by the famous 17th century
Italian architect Borromini Francesco
Borromini, uh, the, uh,
the Cathedral of Saint Peter's
in any of you who've been there.
I will agree with me on this as one
of the great wonders of the world.
There's no question.
It is if you want to talk about
bigger is better or biggest is best.
This is a truly a colossal buildings.
Any of you have been there? No. Uh,
but it does give me occasion to mention
as I've mentioned a couple of times
already this term that one of the really
great things to do when you visit Rome
is decline things is to climb.
If you're so lucky to climb the column
of Trajan or the Pantheon up to the Dome,
those you'd have to get
special permission to do.
But what you don't need special
permission to do. And one is,
it is one of the great climbs in Rome is
to go up Saint Peters and you can go up
Saint Peter's either on the
outside of the building, uh,
to various levels from which you can
see some of the greatest views of Rome,
including back over central Rome,
ancient Rome,
all the buildings that
we've been talking about.
You can see the dome of the Pantheon
from the top of Saint Peter's.
And you can see the victor of
manual monument, tall and proud, uh,
from the dome of Saint Peter's.
But you can also climb up to the,
to the dome from the inside, which is
an another extraordinary experience.
You can go almost,
not quite,
but almost to the apex of Michelangelo's
Dome, Walk Around a Carter.
Uh, they are, and look down on, uh,
Bernini's Baldor keynote. So, uh,
for those of you who are going to Rome
anytime soon or in the future, uh, it's a,
it's a not to be missed
experience to climb, uh,
the Cathedral of Saint Peter's on
the outside and also on the inside.
I bring you to Saint Peter's because w
one can also go down underneath Saint
Peter's.
And that's another very interesting
experience to go down in the depths of
beneath Saint Peter's and get a
really great sense of the centuries of
civilization that had been piled one on
top of another from ancient Rome or from
the time of Romulus, indeed,
all the way up to today. Uh,
and in order to see the
tomb of the [inaudible],
which is a tomb that I want to turn to,
now,
you do have to go down underneath
Saint Peters. You, you have to,
this is something you can't just walk it,
you can climb,
you can climb Saint Peter's
any day of the week,
but if you want to go
underneath Saint Peter's,
you have to make special arrangements.
Uh,
you have to get special tickets to do
that. And now one can do that online.
You can plan that online.
Uh,
and you can get tickets to go to the so
called Vatican cemeteries a underneath,
underneath. And they don't have them.
They have a small number of hours on,
on a variety of days.
So it is something one needs to plan
for well in advance, but you can do it.
You go to the left of
the ball at the Kino,
you go down and you go
down century upon century.
You see primarily the tombs of the pope's,
the crips with the tombs of the popes.
And I show you Pope Boniface here,
just to give you an idea of what some of
these look like lying in eternity here
on the top of his sarcophagus or a space
sculptured portrait of him on the top
of his sarcophagus. But if you go all
the way down, all the way down in,
most tourists don't do this.
But if you go all the way to the bottom,
what you end up with is one of
Rome's great tomb streets. Uh,
and this tomb street was out in the
light of day, of course in antiquity,
like all the other tunes,
streets. But because of the
passage of time, because, uh,
other buildings that were built on top,
primarily the cathedral of Saint Peters,
uh, and just the, the rising ground
level over time, it now is, uh,
it is subterranean. But when you, it's
amazing, you go down, you walk along it,
it is like you are. Well, I mean it's
a dark street. Uh, but nonetheless,
I wouldn't want it. I wouldn't
want to record that in that,
uh, in that street. Uh,
but, uh, you go down under,
it's a dark street, but it is,
you feel like you are walking along
a major, a tomb street in Rome,
and indeed you are.
And I show you a plan of it here so
that you can see it is very much like
walking along the tomb street in east la
soccer. You see at your left and right,
uh, these, uh,
these concrete brick face
tombs that looked very much
like the tumor [inaudible]
Magilla or the ones that
we saw in Isla Socra,
a typical house tombs
of the second century,
a d one of the,
one of the tombs that is located down
there has long been thought by scholars
and believers to be the tomb of St Peter.
Uh,
no one has been able to prove
this. Incontrovertibly but
there is fair, you know,
there is some interesting
evidence both pro and con. Uh,
and it has been thought and you
know, uh, Peters famous, uh,
statement, uh, you know, upon this
rock, I shall build this church,
namely the Church of Saint
Peters. Uh, we believe, uh,
that when Constantine
the last pagan emperor,
and we're going to talk about him
in the last lecture this semester,
when Constantine built the first
basilica Christian basilica on this site,
the basilica that we referred to as old
Saint Peter's that obviously predated
new St Peter's, uh, he, uh, he, uh, he,
we think he may have built it on that
very rock and on that very tomb of St
Peter. And that's what this, uh,
restored view shows you here.
If you walk along though, and look
at these tombs, for the most part,
they look like typical Roman tombs
from the second century, brick face,
concrete construction, uh, with
interesting decoration inside.
And I show you just the most famous
mosaic that is located down there,
which you see is a figure in a chariot.
We think it's a
representation of the Sun God,
Saul or Helios in the cherry cause
you can see the raid crown, uh,
but some believe it is a
representation of Christ as Helios.
And I show it to you only because it is
the single most famous mosaic down there.
And one of the most
famous mosaics in Rome,
but also because it heralds of what
we're going to be begin to see happening,
especially in the last lecture.
And that is this transition from
paganism to Christianity in Rome,
Constantine being the last pagan,
first Christian emperor.
And this interesting a way in which a
pagan imagery aligned into Christian
imagery,
both in terms of of figural decoration,
but also in terms of architecture.
I can't because it's so poorly lighted
down there. I can't show you, uh, the, uh,
a good picture of the tombs
a beneath Saint Peter's.
But I can show you another set of tombs,
uh,
beneath a that they're very well lighted
and can be photograph better, uh,
beneath a, uh, Columbaria
I'm and underground
catacomb actually an underground
burial area that was used by the early
Christians in Rome.
And you see that it's called,
you don't have to worry about it. It's
called the Church of Sansa boss Jonno.
And these, uh, these
tombs are underneath that.
But I showed them to you here just to
give you a sense of what that tomb street
looked like.
A underneath the Vatican or looks like
underneath the Vatican with the concrete
brick faced tombs looking
very similar to those.
We saw these easily Socra the same,
uh,
same travertine door jams and
scriptions slipped windows.
And if you look through the
entrance way of this one,
you will see its barrel vaulted and it
has a scheme that is very similar to the
stucco decoration of the tomb of
the Valarie with these circles, uh,
done in a raised stucco and with the
floating figures in between them.
And this is exactly what it
looks like beneath the Vatican.
I can show you some views of the interiors
of some of the Vatican tombs because
those have lights in them, they're better
lighted. Uh, you can see them here.
We see this interesting combination that
we also saw these [inaudible] of the
smaller niches that are used for,
uh,
earned a and the larger arc Arca Solea
that are used for the placement of
bodies. And then you can see
in this view on the right,
the way in which they have closed off
those Arca Soliah by placing a marble
plaques on them that either
have inscriptions, are
sometimes figural scenes.
And then again here a freestanding
sarcophagi on these interiors as well.
This is an accident,
a metric view from ward Perkins
of the Tomb of the Chi Tainui.
It dates to one 60 Aidy in
the Vatican cemetery in Rome.
And I think you can see here, uh, both
the brick face, concrete construction,
uh, the way in which the
windows have similar stucco
decoration to what we saw on
the tomb of Antioch Gala on the,
via Apia in Rome.
But most interesting for us is the
way in which the interior is treated.
Because this is my type two a
here we will see some Stucco,
but you will see here that the walls
are in live and in a different way.
They are enlivened through architect
tonic means through the use of columns,
through the use of niches or the use
of pediments, triangular pediments, uh,
but also broken triangular pediments.
Here you see a pediment
that has been split apart,
triangular pediment split apart to the,
to show what is inside.
This is the same scheme that we saw in
second style Roman wall painting way back
when.
This whole idea of taking the traditional
vocabulary of architecture and uh,
and Dan and uh,
dealing with it in a very different
way than had been done before. Uh,
breaking the rules so to speak.
We see that happening here.
But the main thing is that
we're looking at at, at these,
this designer using architectural members,
uh,
to create the visual interest
of the walls of the structure.
You can also see in this
accident and metric view,
this combination of a small niches for
cinerary urns and then these larger arc
is Soliah, uh, for the body.
So cremation and inflammation
still going on hand in hand, uh,
during the second century a d this is
a spectacular view of the interior,
of the tomb, of the Chi Taney. And here
you can really see what I mean. Yes,
there is some stucco. If you look at
the vaults, you will see that those,
that there, this is again, a groin vault
that has been stuck out over, uh, and uh,
and uh,
it has the same kind of co had had the
same kind of compartments and painted
decoration relief decoration that we
saw in the tomb of the punk Crotty.
But you can see that most of the effects
have been done through architectural
means.
If you look carefully,
you will see that there is a black and
white mosaic on the floor and not so
different from what we see in Ostia.
Uh, there are niches on the walls.
These niches used for the cinerary
urns, Arca Soliah down here for, uh,
the bodies. Uh, but, uh,
and there are the stucco decoration in
the use of the shells are that you can
see here.
But if you look very carefully at the
combination of sort of Maroon and cherry
red walls,
uh,
you will see the remains of
the architectural members
that serve to enliven in
this space.
Look up here,
you will see that there was a triangular
pediment over the central niche.
You can see parts of the broken triangle,
triangular pediments on either side,
you can see the remains of capitals.
And beneath those would have been the
projecting columns that we saw in the
accident and metric view in ward Perkin.
So this again,
the second type where the walls are
enlivened with architectural members and
those architectural members when intact
would have created a scheme in which you
had progression, recession, progression,
recession all along the wall.
This in and out scheme that we're going
to see becomes the hallmark of what I'm
going to term here this semester.
The Baroque element in Roman antiquity,
enrollment,
architecture,
all of these buildings were being put up
during the reign of Hadrian. Successor.
Hadrian had died in a 138 and he was
succeeded by a man by the name of Antonio
as pious, whose portrait you
see here on the upper right.
And tonight as pious again, uh, was, uh,
he reigned for a quite long time.
He a rain between one 38 and 161 a d
it was a period of extraordinary piece.
He liked Hadrian was a peace loving man.
He was able to maintain that peace
exceedingly well and Rome really thrived
under his emperorship.
He's also interesting because he seems
to have had more of a love relationship
with his wife than any other Roman
emperor that I can think of a,
a relationship that was so
strong that when his wife died,
he became emperor.
Here's his wife [inaudible] the elder,
when he became emperor in,
he became emperor when 38.
But she died already in 141.
And as I mentioned,
he stayed on for four until one 61.
So he was emperor for 20 more years
after her death. He never forgot her.
He stayed and he stayed, you
know, completely enamored
of her. He never remarried.
We don't even have any, any, any,
any rumors that he had any
concubines or anything like that.
He seems to have stayed
completely true to her. And uh,
what's interesting is that,
uh, when the two of them died,
their successors of Marcus Aurelius and
Lucius verus put up a monument to them,
and it's not on your monument. Listen,
I'm not holding you responsible for it,
but I just want to show it to you because
it will eliminate a monument that I am
going to show you in a moment. Uh,
this, this, uh, base which was,
which served as the base for a porphyry
column that was located on top.
Uh,
it represents a scene in which we see a
[inaudible] as and his wife Festina the
elder being carried to heaven on
the back of a male personification.
We see Roma in the bottom right,
and she is saluting them.
She is bearing witness to what is a
representation of their joint divinization
the two of them Falstino the elder
divinized that her death in one 41 and
tinnitus pious divinize
at his death in one 61.
And yet we see them being carried to
heaven as if they're divinization has
happened exactly at the same time.
This is obviously a fiction.
It is conflation of time. Uh, it is a
fiction of which the Romans were a pet,
particularly adept in their
sculptural representations.
But I show it to you here because
it has some bearing on, uh,
a temple that I now want to talk about.
This is the so called Temple of
Antonius Pius and Faustina, the elder.
It is a temple that Antonius Pius put
up in honor of his wife in one 41 to her
as a diva after she was divinized.
Uh, but at his own death,
20 years later in one 61,
his successors again Marcus a release
and Lucius verus a rededicated it to the
two of them to the divine and to non
as pious and to the divine fell, Stena.
It is quite well preserved today and
it is important for two main reasons.
It is important because it is our best
surviving temple that was put up to an
emperor and an embrace.
It wasn't the only one,
but it's the best surviving
example of that. Uh,
and it is another example of the way in
which antiquities are reused over time
in other contexts and at later times.
And how that reuse sometimes
helps to preserve them.
What I show you now on the screen
is a coin on the upper left, uh,
representing Fao, Stena the elder on
the odd verse of the coin on the left,
her portrait,
and it refers to her as diva Palestina.
So it is a coined that and tonight is,
is struck after her death
and after her divinization.
And we see on the back the
temple that n to nine is pious,
originally made in her honor.
Over here we see a series of sketch of
drawings that come from the Ward Perkins
Textbook that show once again a
depiction of that original temple on the,
on the coin,
and with a legend that says,
I Tearny toss for eternity because
now she is a diva for eternity.
And then a restored view over here of
what the temple would've looked like after
it was rededicated to and
tinnitus and Faustina in one 61.
And then over here,
uh,
the Baroque building that was built into
it in the 17th century had when it was
turned into the Church of
San Lorenzo in Miranda.
And I put the names on the Renzo
and Miranda on your monument list.
If we look at the view of it as it
was after it was rededicated to,
and tonight as pious and Faustina,
we will see a typical Roman temple.
All the features that we have described.
So very often in the course of
this semester, the deep porch,
the freestanding columns in the
porch and the very tall podium, uh,
the single staircase, the facade
emphasis, we see all of that, uh,
here. Very, uh, very tip,
a very conventional Roman temple with
sculpture in the pediment and a decoration
on the eaves of the temple as well.
What we see in the bottom left is what
happened to this temple in the 17th
century. Part of it was preserved.
Uh, maybe more of it was preserved.
We're not absolutely sure, but at least
part of it was preserved. The walls,
the sidewalls, uh, and also
the columns and the, um,
the front of the well, the sidewalls
primarily and the columns. And the,
uh, the lintel over here that has the
inscription that dedicates the temple to,
and tonight as pious and foul Stina.
But what you see behind it is the baroque
facade rising up a baroque facade that
has buttresses.
And I'm going to show it
to you in actuality in a
moment that has buttresses on
either side that has this wonderful
split RQ weighted pediment,
a split RQ weighted pediment that
would have been impossible to conceive,
I believe, without these architects,
baroque architects of 17th century.
Looking back, uh, to the Baroque element
in Roman antiquity, the cross is,
is added in the center of course,
but there's one major difference
between this building and this building.
Does anyone see what that is
besides the addition
of the Baroque facade?
What little louder.
Okay.
The podium. Exactly. Emily
Wright. The podium is not there.
The podium is not there.
The staircase is not there.
Why is that Emily?
I don't know if it up like
yes,
you can see it a little.
Yes.
The ground level has risen so that at
the time that they decide to turn the
temple event and not as pious and
fell into Song Lorenzo in Miranda,
this is where the ground level is.
There's no podium anymore.
The podium is completely underground.
As our part of the columns,
we see only the part of the car.
So they put the door at the,
at the bottom. Oh, what is the
bottom at that particular time?
Now let me show you the building today.
It's very well preserved.
So you see what I mean by the best
preserved a monument to the best preserve
temple to an emperor and an emphasis
in Rome, extremely well preserved.
You see its location is in the Roman
forum with the backdrop of the imperial
fora behind it. The forum of Augustus
Forum of Trajan in the Roman forum.
So prime real estate, uh, for this temple.
When Antonius Pius pious
decides to build it to his wife.
We see here the original podium,
the original staircase,
the original columns, gray granite
columns, white marble capitals.
We see the original lintel with the
inscription still preserve to divine Anta
nine as pie as to divine Faustina.
We see the original two
full walls of the side.
We see the lintel on this
side that also has a,
a freeze that is preserved from antiquity.
And then we see growing up behind it,
the 17th century Baroque church with uh,
it's buttresses and with its
broken, uh, RQ weighted pediment.
And if you look very carefully,
you will see this is,
this was ground level in the 17th century.
This is the 17th century door.
This is the ancient door down here.
I'll show you a couple of views where
you can see that even more clearly.
Here's another view showing you
those great gray granite columns,
the white capitals, the 17th
century door, and then down here,
the ancient door,
which shows you more dramatically than
anything else I've been able to show you
this semester. This change and
ground level. And two more views, uh,
that I took that show you the same here,
the 17th century doors.
So you have to think of all of this
underground in the 17th century.
And then only in more modern
times, uh, was the, uh,
was the temple excavated temple in church
excavated down to their original level.
Here's another view showing you again,
the 17th century doorway,
the earlier doorway, the staircase,
a little baby down here, uh,
which I was happy to have four scale.
Uh,
it gives you a sense once again of how,
and that makes it even more dramatic
because I don't know if it's a he or she.
Um, she, she, uh, sit sitting there, uh,
that she, uh, it makes it even more
dramatic to demonstrate to you, again,
since this is a lecture on
bigger is better that this
temple to nine is and fell.
Stena was also very,
very also is very,
very large in scale.
When an to nine is pious,
died in one 61.
He was succeeded by Marcus Aurelius and
Lucius verus mark is a really released,
one of the most famous of the Roman
emperors, the great stoic philosopher.
And you see him in a portrait here you
see Lucius verus on the left hand side.
The two of them, uh, were co
emperors between one 61 and one 69,
uh,
Lucius verus died in battle and one 69
Marcus or release continued on alone
until the year 180 a d.
So he too had a very long rein.
Marcus spent most of his reign,
however, on the front during
the period that he was emperor,
the barbarians were
literally at the gates.
There was concern that they were
going to in fact overrun the city,
completely overrun the empire completely.
And he had to spend most of his reign
on the frontiers. Uh, and he did, uh,
beating back those barbarians.
For that reason,
there was very little
architectural construction,
even though he had a very long reign.
There was very little architectural
construction during the time of Marcus
Aurelius, uh, because of, uh,
the, that he had to spend in war.
He was succeeded by his son.
Comedies whose portrait you see down here,
a comedy in the line,
also in the,
in the megaloads maniacal
line of a Nero and Domitian,
a man who saw himself as a god on earth
who saw himself as the Greek hero,
Hercules. He called himself
self Hercules' Romanos. Uh,
and we see him in his most famous and
most fabulous is about one of the best
portraits preserved from ancient Rome.
It's in the capital, I'm museums today.
And you see him masquerading here
as Hercules, uh, with his, uh,
with the lion skin around
his head holding the club,
holding the apples of the Hispera cities,
demonstrating that he has completed that
last labor justice Hercules had done
and is going to become a god
in the manner of Hercules.
He used to parade around
in Rome openly in this way,
and actually struck coins showing himself
as Hercules Romanos just to get to
give you a sense of how extreme it was.
And he was always challenging people to,
uh, to, um, to, to hand to
hand combat. Uh, and in fact,
he eventually got his comeuppance because
although he himself also range for
quite a while between one 81 92.
So he lasted for 12 years.
But nonetheless, even his closest, uh,
his closest advisors eventually turned
against him and plotted behind his back
and arranged for the most, one of the
most famous gladiators of the day,
Narcissus interestingly called
Narcissus, uh, to, to, uh,
take up comedy.
This is a common,
this is offered to fight anybody. Oh,
wanted to fight him in the Colosseum. Uh,
and of course he thought that being
him for protected him and that he,
he liked Nero who fixed the Olympic
Games in his favor, that, that, uh,
that communists would also never lose
in a contest like this because he was by
definition emperor. Uh, but his
advisers turned against him. Let,
let narcis is loose and communist was
slain by narcissists in the Colosseum.
Uh, but he did, I, I do want to just
mention, and only in passing comment is,
did put up a column to his father,
Marcus and release a that is based very
closely on the column of Trajan in Rome.
I'm not going to go into it with you
today because the architectural complex in
which it was originally
found no longer survives,
but I just wanted you to be aware that
the column of Trajan was succeeded by the
column of Marcus released.
I want to, however,
returned for the rest of the lecture
to a new dynasty that came to the fore
after the end of the so
called and nine emperors.
When communists died, there were
no more and to nines to succeed.
Him and Rome, once again,
fell into a civil war.
And there were rivals warring with
one another for supreme power.
And the man who came to the fore was
a man by the name of pertinent facts.
P. E. R. T. I. N. A Ex. Uh,
but he had other rivals.
And one of them was the man who
eventually really came on out on top.
And His name was Lucius Septimius
saveras Lucia Septimius.
The bears was within that
year between 92 and 93,
able to get rid of not only pertinent
acts but other rivals and become supreme
ruler of Rome.
And because he liked Vespasian before
him had two sons to succeed him Caracalla
and data,
he was able to set up a new dynasty.
The so called Severen what
we call the sovereign SCV,
ran the Severen dynasty in Rome,
the Severen dynasty and Rome,
extremely important because September
Severus commissioned some important
structures,
both public structures and private.
He was an interesting emperor because
he combined an interest in the two.
And then his son Caracalla,
who epitomizes as I began today,
the whole bigger is better
or biggest is best, uh,
philosophy in life and in architecture.
I want to show you first just to
introduce you to these two patrons. Uh,
this wonderful painted Tondo,
uh,
that is preserved from Rome.
It was, was found, excuse me,
not in Rome, but in Egypt,
uh, and is now in the
museum, a museum in Berlin.
But it is important because it is our
only surviving painting of an emperor.
And not only an emperor,
but an emperor and his whole family,
his wife and his children. The only
surviving painting of an emperor today.
But there were obviously
many of these in antiquity.
It's a fascinating painting we see set.
Timmy is severity with his gray hair and
beard and his wonderful jeweled crown.
We see his wife, Julia Domino,
who buy, oh, and by the
way, I neglected to mention,
but one of the interesting things about,
uh,
about Septimius Severus his biography
is the fact that he was born not in Rome
and not in Spain,
is Trajan and Hadrian had been,
but rather in north Africa in a place
called Leptin is Magdna, Lep, t, t,
I s, new word, m, a,G , N, a in
[inaudible], born in North Africa.
He hooked up with a woman from
Syria, uh, whose name was Juliet Dom.
She was the daughter of an important
priest in Syria called Bossy, ANA's.
Uh, she was famous in Rome for
her wigs. She used to wear wigs,
and you can see her wearing one of her
wigs in this wonderful painted portrait.
She also clearly liked jewelry because
you can see her with these fabulous, uh,
triple pearl earrings and a wonderful,
uh,
pearl necklace here. Also,
uh, looking very vibrant, uh,
in this portrait. And then the two of
them with their sons, their elder son,
car color over here, and their younger
son, or what remains of him. Uh,
gala on the left, uh, Gava and gay to,
and Caracalla succeeded their
father together as co rulers,
but, uh, Carra call a very
jealous of his brother,
who was much more popular with the Roman
populace. Then Caracalla himself was a,
and Caracalla eventually had
his brother murdered, uh,
and after his brother
was murdered, he, uh,
he convinced that as Caracalla convinced
the Roman Senate to issure issue a dop,
not tio memoria or damnation
of the memory of data.
And an attempt was made to eradicate
data from history by eradicating and from
art. And you can see that he was snuffed
out, his face was removed on this,
but then it was left to stand to show
the power that Carra call a had to
destroy, uh, his brother.
As you can see here,
this gives you a glimpse into
the mind and psyche of Caracalla.
I want to show you first though,
to buildings before we look at
the baths of Caracalla up. Uh,
I do want to show you two
buildings, uh, of Septimius Savara.
It's a public building.
First,
the so-called arch of the
severity and the Roman forum,
and then an extension
to the palatine palace.
The arch of me severity and the
Roman forum dates to add 203,
and it commemorates a the
Parthian victory of Septimius.
Severna Septimius Severus
I already mentioned to you,
came to power in a civil war.
So like Augustus and like
Vespasian before him.
He needed to gain legitimacy by
having an important foreign victory.
And he does this by looking east
as Augustus had done before.
Him Looking to Parthenia,
uh,
and does war with Partha and in fact
has an important victory and celebrates
that important victory in this triumphal
arch that is put up in his honor in 203
Aidy in once again,
the choices spot a real estate in Rome,
the forum Romana the Roman Forum.
I show you a Google earth view over here.
We've seen this one before,
so you've undoubtedly got
this one memorized by now.
There's Google Earth image of the
Roman forum as it looks today with the
coliseum up there with the via de Fori
am periodically imperial for over here,
the circus maximus,
the Palatine Hill,
the comp Udofia capital on hill
is redesigned by Michelangelo,
the wedding cake of Victor Emmanuel
here between the [inaudible] and the
coliseum, we see, of course the
remains of the ancient Roman forum,
much lower ground level than the
modern ground level. Uh, you'll recall,
uh,
the location of the Temple of Venus in
Roma just underneath the coliseum of the
arch of Titus on the Veolia.
Uh,
and you should remember also that we
talked way in the beginning of the term
about two arches to succeed. Successive
arches built in honor of Augustus.
First his act in victory,
victory enact Actium and then his victory
over the Parthians, which is over here.
And then, uh, if we look very close,
it's a little hard to see when I'm up
this close, but we look very closely.
We will see the location,
I think it's roughly around
here of the arch of is severity.
We can see it better in this,
a plan of the Roman forum as a developed
between the third and seventh centuries
a d we see the top Yulara and at the top,
which means we're close
to the Capitoline hill.
We see two basilicas that were put
up in the Republican period. Uh,
we see a temple that we did not study
that was put up in honor of the divine
Julius Caesar by Augustus.
We see the speakers platform,
we see the Senate House, which I
will show you in a later lecture. Uh,
and over here we see the location of
what was originally the acting arch of
Augustus and then the Parthian arch of
Augustus and remember that the Parthian
arch of Augustus had a triple opening.
I and then if you look
at the rest of the plan,
you will see the location of the
arch of Septimius Rivera's over there
diagonally across in dialogue with
the Parthian arch of Augustus.
Was this coincidence?
Absolutely not.
This was clearly very
carefully orchestrated by
September to severity and his
advisors to build his Parthian arch
in dialogue with the Parthian arch of
Augustus with regard to its form,
it also made reference
to the Augusta and arch.
I show you here the arch of
Septimus severity as it looks today.
It is our first example that we've seen
this semester of a Roman arch with a
triple open, a triple RQ
weighted opening, a large RQ,
wade RQ weighted opening in the center,
flanked by two smaller
lower RQ weighted entrance.
We have not seen that before.
First surviving example in Rome.
Will we remember? If we look,
think back to the arches.
We have explored from
the time of Augustus on,
you'll remember that they
are single bade arches.
Augustus is acting arch,
the arch of Titus and even the second
century arch of Trajan at a Vento.
But as I've already said today,
the,
if we look back to the coin,
the arch no longer exists,
but we look back to a coin depiction
of the Parthian arch of Augustus.
It had three openings,
a central RQ weighted opening and
then two rectangular openings.
Trey be aided openings with
pediments on either side flanking it.
So this is not the Parthian arch of
Augustus is not a triple RQ weighted arch,
but it is a three opening arch.
And I think there is no question that
those three openings are being alluded to
in the Severn arch and being and being
transformed into something that was new,
which was the idea of the triple arcuate
and bay or maybe it wasn't so new
because there's an arch,
the arch that you see down here in the
south of France at [inaudible] and we'll
look at this arch when we,
when we make our journey to the south
of France in an upcoming lecture, uh,
we will look at this arch and it's,
it's a triple bait arch,
just like the arch of
September [inaudible] severity.
It's covered with sculpture,
just like the arch of Septum is severity.
So for a while there were scholars who
dated this to the time of September.
He is severities,
although put up in the provinces
a bought a recent scholarship,
more reasons scholarship has demonstrated,
scholars have looked at the
piles of arms and armor on here.
And identified it as piles of arms and
armor that had to do with battles that
took place in the south of France or what
is now the south of France in the age
of Augustus.
There's also an inscription referring to
a specific historical figure who lived
during the time, the late period of
Augustus and into the time of Tiberius.
So it seems very likely that this is not
a sever and arch, but a tie Berian arch.
Uh, and I show it to you here
only because while we usually,
and this may be helpful to some
of you who are doing, uh, papers,
topics or city plans in the provinces,
uh,
we usually think of ideas flowing
from the center to the periphery.
But here we seem to have an idea that
comes to the fore first in the periphery
and then ends up ultimately in the center.
Although of course there are lots of
missing pieces to the ancient puzzle.
I mean, there are lots of monuments
that have not come down to us.
So it is not inconceivable that a triple
bade arch was built in Rome earlier,
but we just have no evidence for it.
I want to show you the arch itself very
quickly because it's mainly a work of
sculpture. But just to show you the three
bays victories in the spandrels river.
God's down here in scription at the top,
you'll have to imagine the great bronze
Quad Droga of the emperor at the apex,
uh,
decorated bases down here but most
interesting are the panels that we see.
Four panels that we see,
two on either side of the arch.
And I show you a detail,
a very good detail of one of them here.
Although it's weathered, you
can see it quite well. Uh,
you can see that this panel,
instead of having full length figure
standing on a single ground line as we saw
for example, in the, uh, in the,
in the freeze of the our pockets,
we see figures on a number of tears here,
small figures on a number of tears.
It should remind you of the scenes on
the column of Trajan. Those spiral,
the spiral freeze with the individual
figures telling the story of Ward.
In this case the Parthian more of
of uh, September. He is severity.
Uh, but, and so what I
think happened here, my, my,
my theory and there are
others who've said the same,
is that what happened to your,
is that the designer of this got the
idea to take excerpts in a sense from the
columns of trades under the column of
mark is a release and put them in panel
format on this monument. Uh, whether,
I don't know whether,
you know,
you can think to yourselves whether
you think this is successful or not.
I think it probably was not deemed to
be particularly successful because it is
the only arch design of its type.
No one picked up afterwards and
imitated this particular eye.
Dia the basis down below
representing Romans,
bringing back Parthian prisoners.
I want to speak very briefly also,
uh, about, uh, uh,
Septimius saveras is extension of the
Imperial Palace on the Palatine Hill.
He extended it to the south.
He lived there just like
every emperor since demission.
He extended it on the southern side.
That's the side nearest the forum.
And he added a facade,
a to it,
a very elaborate facade
that does not survive.
It doesn't survive because we know it
was torn down in 1588 to 1589 by one of
the pope's because the pope wanted
to use it in his own paypal building,
wanted to use the building materials in
his own paypal building. But fortunately,
uh, the artist Martin von
Heemskerck, the renaissance artists,
and I put his name on the monument list
for you. Martin von Heemskerck, uh,
uh, drew some of it while
it was being dismantled.
And you see a piece of it over here
in the Martin von Heemskerck drawing.
There's also a, uh, a,
uh, the, um, the, um,
plan of this structure also
preserved on the forma orbis.
And we can see that marble plan
of Rome from the Severn period.
We take both of those,
that evidence together.
We can reconstruct it quite effectively.
We can see that it was a, a,
a facade that look very
much like a theater, uh,
with wings on either side with apses here,
three large apses,
uh,
and columns inside those apps is with
other elements that have columns in three
tiers looking very much like a theater
stage set all done in marble. Uh,
it might have been also a fountain.
There might've been a base in
down here with a water display.
All of this serving as a new facade for
dimensions palace on the Palatine Hill.
It's important because it's
another example of this use
of progression recession
progression, recession, uh,
Kloss across the facade to give an in
and out undulating movement using the
traditional vocabulary of architecture
in a way that is striking and in a way
that it again, Harold's, this new
baroque style in Roman architecture.
I also mentioned, uh, just as the last
point about this monument that we also,
the reason it's called the CEP disodium
or the CEP disodium and you see that
name on the monument list for you.
The reason is referred to as
a step disodium is because
it was thought to honor
the or to commemorate the seven planets,
uh,
which is not surprising in the orbit
of symptom you severities and Julia
dominant because we know that Julia
dominant was an avid follower of
astrological signs,
used to predict what was going to
happen in her husband's a rain, uh,
through those signs.
And this is likely a nod to her particular
astrological interests and the in the
nine or 10 minutes that remain,
I want to end today with
this extraordinary imperial
bath structure that was
designed at the behest of the Emperor
Caracalla when Septicemia severities died
in two 11.
He was succeeded by car call and by Gayda
I've already told you what Caracalla
did to get rid of data.
Uh,
and Caracalla became sole emperor in 212
212 id and remained emperor until his
death in 217 a d a and one of his major
commissions was this imperial bath
structure.
He wanted to eight his father because
we know that Septum Mya Savara said also
built a major public bath. And
roam the tear my Septa, me on. I,
they do not survive.
We have very little knowledge of them.
So there isn't anything that I can
show you or tell you about them.
But we know he built it.
So like father like son,
he wanted to outdo his father's is like
Bush one Bush to wanting to outdo his
father and to build an even
larger, uh, bathing establishment.
And he does it here in Rome,
a a bathing establishment called
the baths of Caracalla or the tear.
My Antonia Neon.
I as of Caracalla dates to 212 to 216.
And uh, any of you who have seen it
will agree with me. This is one if you,
if we hadn't have been outrageous
for them was the mother of all forms.
This is certainly the mother of
all imperial bath structures.
This is quite something. Uh, fortunately,
much of it survives mainly
the concrete shell, uh,
sh concrete shell of itself. Uh, but, uh,
we can see the outlines here
in this Google earth image,
which shows you not
only the bathing block,
but also part of the
precinct that surrounded it.
Because we shall see if we look at
a plan of the baths of Caracalla,
which you see here in the bottom left.
This is a detail of
just the bathing block.
And if we compare the general plan with
the plan of the bads of Trajan in Rome,
we will see that the bands of Trajan,
which were very large in their own day,
have been exceeded,
succeeded here in terms of size,
but are very much in the same
general format. By that, I mean,
I large bathing block here
inside a larger precinct.
That precinct has around it,
a host of rooms that were used as lecture
halls and seminar rooms and Greek and
Latin libraries. So again, great
locus of intellectual as well as uh,
as, as wellness, uh, in the city of
Rome in the third century, a d, uh,
we see that in the baths of Caracalla
just as if we look at the bathing block,
just as in the bads of Trajan,
we see that all the main bathing rooms,
which were used both for men and women,
but probably at different times of
Day are aligned with one another.
We see the great figure Doriam here
with the triple groin vault over that
buttressed by rooms with
barrel bolts on either side.
We see a conventional,
a vertically oriented tepid
Doriam essentially a rectangle
here leading into the
call Darren.
So all of these analysis Brigador him
tepid Arrium called RM called Arrium
around dish, a structure
with alcoves, uh, and uh,
but very large in scale.
In fact,
you'll be interested to hear that
the span of the Dome of the call,
Darian of the baths of Caracalla was
almost as large as the span of the,
at the Dome of the Pantheon in Rome.
Just to get you,
give you a sense of the extraordinary,
bigger is better scale. Uh,
in this particular bath over
here, a Natacha Geo located
where it usually isn't,
but here on access with the other rooms
and interesting to talk to Ya with a
scallop aside,
screened by columns and then otherwise
all the rooms symmetrically disposed
around two polestar I one on either side,
matching room symmetrically disposed
around the central building blocks.
So the same imperial bath structure type
a that we saw developed under Titus and
Trajan but taken too
much larger scale here.
This model shows you
that the, the, the whole,
here we are looking back at the walls
which were very plain on three sides
toward the Taco, toward
the vaulting of the, uh,
of the frigging Darian.
And then the Dome as you can
see there of the caldarium.
Interesting is the,
uh,
the front side of the or the the side
where you can see the caldarium projecting
over here,
which you can see is opened up much more
than the other sides with a series of
columns,
uh,
screened columns a and then columns
screening and opening up the call,
Darian as well on the southern
side of the monument. Uh,
just a few views to give you a sense of
what this structure looks like today.
Again, it's mainly piles of
concrete, uh, faced with brick. Uh,
but you can see some of the soaring
vaults still there. This is a, this is,
this is in fact, uh, you know,
this is even in this view,
it's much smaller than it would have
been because so much of the ceilings and
the bolts are missing today.
But you can get a sense by looking at this
family of four, a standing next to it,
the colossal scale of the
baths of Caracalla in Rome.
Here's another view with some tourists
as well, uh, to also give you a sense of,
and this is very incomplete today,
but it still gives you some idea
of the colossal magnitude, uh,
of this particular bath structure.
As one walks through it,
there's actually very little, uh,
ornamental decorations still preserved,
but there was plenty in antiquity you can
see here and there some fragments of a
freeze. This is a restored view of what
the Frig Darian would have looked like,
the most important room in the bath, which
would have been tripled groin vaulted,
as you can see here, which would have had
gray granite columns with white marble.
Capital's a and would have had
an incredible sculptural display,
uh,
and Caracalla like demission before him
remembered emissions Al Reggio and those
colossal statues of Dionysus and Apollo,
uh,
with whom demission wanted to
associate himself Caracalla, uh,
of the same ilk who also wanted to ally
himself with great heroes of the past,
a great gods of the past.
And he follows the lead of communists
and who's in, who's mode and model. He,
he, he kind of, and he looked back again
to Nero Domitian to communists. Uh,
and he, he, he likens himself to Hercules.
And we have sculpture that is preserved
from the Darian that represents
Hercules, Hercules, the weary,
the famous weary Hercules type.
This is now in Naples. And
the Archeological Museum
[inaudible] the statute,
but it comes from the frigging
Darian up the baths of Caracalla.
We're absolutely sure of that. And
it depicts the weary Hercules. Uh,
it is a Roman copy. Uh, the
artists, we know his name,
I put his name on the monument
list for you, Gli con of Athens.
So an Athenian sculptor working in
the time of Caracalla makes this copy,
but he makes it a very of a very
famous last Greek original by the Greek
sculptor lie sipfest, whose name is
also on your monument list, a, uh,
a work of art that he originally
made in the three thirties BC.
So glycone of Athens copies lie.
Sip is also a grease this statue
at the behest, again of Caracalla.
And the fact that this was a theme or
a light motif that ran through all the
decoration of the frigging Darian is
underscored by the fact that a composite
capitol that survives also
from the Frig, Darian, uh,
shows a figure of that same weary Hercules
interspersed with the canvas leaves
of that capital.
So again,
a very carefully orchestrated program
to try to underscore the relationships
between Caracalla and Hercules,
uh,
mosaics a black and a geometric mosaics.
And not unlike those in Ostia found
a and still exist in the bas of car.
Call it today, black and
white with a little addition
of color here. Another, uh,
another section that shows you the
interest in geometry as well as floral
motifs.
Uh,
this detail that you can also see on the
state sites still today showing the see
scenes that we're not [inaudible],
we're the kind of scenes one
would expect in a bath. Uh,
very similar to those that Ostia but
done in a somewhat more of a better way.
And then the PS to raise this daunts
I think of the mosaics of the baths of
Caracalla and WellPreserved today,
uh,
was a mosaic that you can see his curve
to s two s to be placed into a room of
this shape that depict on the floor all
the famous athletes and gladiators of
the day,
either in full length statues or and full
length images or in a portrait images.
Uh, and I don't doubt that these would
have been recognizable stars, superstars,
you know,
the Alex Rodriguez of their day a
superstars flexing their muscles for the
public and hoping to be recognized
by everyone who came to this bath.
And you can just imagine men and women
standing above looking and trying to pick
out who is depicted here.
Here's another view that I took
that is in its current location,
which is in the Vatican museums in Rome.
That's where one needs to go to see what
survives up this wonderful mosaic with
the athletes and gladiators of the day.
And I showed them to you here as well.
And if you look at these, you can see that
they not only are shown, you know, some,
some are already Victor's, some are taking
part in their sport. Uh, but once again,
just as in the Alexander Mosaic,
we see the use of a lot of different
colored tests awry. We see cast shadows.
This is very well done. Wonderful. Uh,
facial configurations done by what must
have been the leading mosaicism of the
day for the baths of Caracalla.
And just in closing today,
I thought I would show you a,
a one of those heads blown up,
uh,
to poster size as you can see here,
but also put it next to an
actual portrait of Caracalla.
This is not important as a course in
sculpture, but I wanted to show this to,
especially since it's a
portrait that you can see,
it's in New York at the
Metropolitan Museum of art,
a very powerful portrait
of a very intense,
a Roman emperor. As you can see
on the left. But I think there is,
there is some relationship between the
way in which the sculptors have depicted
Caracalla with his very cubic and abstract
face is short military hairstyle and
the depictions of the
athletes and the gladiator.
So I think he was not only
trying to, uh, to, uh,
draw a relationship between
himself and Hercules Romanos,
but also between himself and some of the
greatest athletes and gladiators of the
day to underscore his strength as
a leader. It was all for naught,
ultimately. Uh, but
nonetheless, he achieved it.
And I think it also speaks to him
as a man with that bigger is better
philosophy.
Thank you.